décima segunda jornada de protestas
contra la impopular reforma pensional de
macron que busca aumentar la edad de
jubilación de 62 a 64 años la decisión
del gobierno de no pasar el proyecto por
la asamblea desató más la ira de los
franceses que salieron nuevamente en
masa el movimiento Busca demostrar que
se mantiene fuerte en vísperas de la
decisión del Consejo constitucional
sobre la legalidad del proyecto
la expresión no queremos que haya
ninguna expresión violenta ni ninguna
presión de ningún tipo sobre ninguna
institución de la República el consejo
constitucional tiene derecho a la
serenidad de los debates y tiene derecho
a que la decisión que se adopte sea cual
sea sea respetada por todos
la cantidad de asistentes ha venido en
declive desde la primera movilización de
hace tres meses pero los sindicatos no
ceden y acusan al gobierno de hacer
oídos sordos una mayoría de franceses
aún respalda las huelgas estamos en una
situación de crisis porque no ha
funcionado y es porque las
organizaciones sindicales no tienen ni
voz ni voto en los temas que se ponen
sobre la mesa temas que conciernen en
particular al mundo del trabajo los
paros han provocado interrupciones en
los servicios de transporte además en el
5% de las escuelas que no están de
vacaciones esta semana personalmente
creo que hay que pasar a la siguiente
etapa es decir es decir bloquear la
economía
el gobierno argumenta que la ley es
esencial para garantizar que el sistema
de pensiones de Francia No quiebre si el
tribunal aprueba finalmente el proyecto
el gobierno podrá promulgar la ley lo
que podría encender nuevamente las
calles de Francia